sowas macht kollege huh
nein ich hatte mir nur so eine zahl auf
maximal in einer geheimen einig sie
waren in einem geheimen club nein es
gibt keine klubs ich hab mir die zahl
der tage auf geschrieben die wir jetzt
schon im chor ohne lok da sind mir kommt
es vor wie 15 jahre in china graf von
monte christo mache ich immer so zu
zeichnen an meine zelle
dafür habe ich immerhin meine zu einer
guten orgie die wir nicht mehr führen
dürfen weil die bundeskanzlerin als ich
über öffnungs diskussions orgien beklagt
hat zu einer guten gewissen übrigens der
honig den habe ich hier mitgebracht und
natürlich aus der französischen
botschaft denn da kann man ihn auch
ernten weil ich ein guter europäer bin
insofern ich finde ich kann das noch ein
bisschen aushalten also sie sehen ich
bin auch ein bisschen macho aber noch
nicht ganz so manchmal ist mir jetzt mal
ganz kurz mal spaß macht ich finde das
echt interessant also vielleicht ist
diese corona krise ist auch der moment
wo alle leute sich zwar voneinander
distanzieren aber sich eben gleichzeitig
auch näher kommen durch diese gemeinsame
geteilte erfahrung und bei mir hat das
zum beispiel die folge dass ich mich
schlechter konzentrieren die noch
schlechter konzentrieren kann dass ich
immer noch weniger einen gesagt haben
übrigen hat ganz viele leute gesagt zu
hören und zu sehen unsere sendung dass
wir uns zu viel ins wort fallen
vielleicht versuchen sie sich jetzt mal
was es an nichts
das entspricht meiner allgemeinen bio
kurve dass ich das gar nicht mehr
richtig kannten ich falle niemandem
ernst weil da vergeht einfach mehr zeit
wenn sie ich sie ausreden lassen ist
schon einfach wieder ein teil des tages
auch warum das sagen sind sie mir ins
wort gefallen das nennt man also eine
performative widerspruch übrigens
eröffnungs diskussions auge in auge
vielen dank ich finde das ja ganz
interessant dass jetzt immer von
lockerungen geredet wird ein begriff den
ich war früher ja gerichtsreporter und
den ich eigentlich aus dem strafvollzug
eine lockerung geben das hat im straf
wollten das ist so ich kenne das im
fitnessstudio nicht mehr hingehen würde
aber da gibt es auch lockerungsübungen
das ist jetzt nicht nur knastis diese
ausmachen oder quasi irgendwas
zusammenklappen dass sie nach ansicht
von genua war sagt man lockerungen
1was verbale lockerungsübung macht die
ab und zu und fing cops rutschte auf der
maus aus also ich kenne den begriff nach
vorne aber jetzt mal im ernst in unserem
bus herum die wirtschaft leidet wirklich
und quietscht wobei jetzt auch nicht
jeder solo selbstständige muss man
ehrlich sagen es gibt auch solo
selbstständige die waren so
selbstständig weil sie ja keine anderen
gefunden haben wir den scheiß mitmachen
wollte den sie da machen für geld oder
glauben machen zu können für geld aber
immerhin die wirtschaft leidet wirklich
gebe ich auch zu 78 prozent hat mit
daimler gerade gewinneinbruch gemeldet
et cetera als hätte ich finde man könnte
jetzt langsam wirklich mal locker weil
ich nicht verstehe dass man in
möbelmarkt darf aber nicht in einem
restaurant
da könnte man ja abstände genauso gut
halten und diese debatte läuft jetzt und
darum hat angela merkel leider eine
tolle performance hingelegt hat bislang
in echten fehler gemacht den leuten noch
mal so sagen stopp durch den diskus
ihren diskutieren ich will diese öffnung
diskussion nicht haben das fand ich
wirklich schwach schwächer als sie
bislang war in wahrheit denn sonst
dieser mittelweg den wieder gehen als
land als bundesländer meint wir als
kommunen der ist ja eigentlich der
richtige weg also ich hab sie merke ich
dass sie aus reden weil ich nehme das
sehr ernst wenn solche zuschriften uns
erreichen
dann bin ich ja sehr response jetzt
sozusagen ich habe im internet mich auch
diese mieten diese frage gestellt warum
man eben zum beispiel in eine kirche
nicht gehen durfte jahr zu wenig arbeit
in einen baumarkt und dann kam eben als
antwort dass jesus christus keine große
hilfe sein wenn man ein verstopftes klo
hat das war sozusagen dann fand ich
einerseits ganz lustig andere als merkte
man da auch dass gerade solche leute
vielleicht tatsächlich einem besuch in
der kirche wenn ich sie nicht untersagen
kann müssen sie auch mal enden ja das
ist so quasi konstitutiv für dieses
gespräch hat diesen führungsmannschaft
krone offensichtlich zu einem erhöhten
nervosität level also sie haben eben
gesagt was sie sprachen vom mittel ist
dass wir dadurch einen mittelweg haben
und ich würde jetzt tätig
dagegengehalten dieser mittelweg den wir
da haben
der scheint mir genau der falsche zu
sein denn es ist ja so dass biologen
dann ist man ist unter sich damals alles
nervt sein ehrlich jetzt will ich mal
auf jetzt virologen epidemiologen sagen
es wird jetzt schon zuviel gelockert ist
wohl zu schnell gelockert die
bundeskanzlerin macht sich darüber große
sorgen sagt wir verlieren sozusagen
unseren ganzen gewonnenen vorsprung
andererseits sagt armin laschet und ich
würde sagen auch der rest des landes
inzwischen freunde
wenn wir jetzt nicht langsam mal wieder
in die gänge kommen ist hier nichts mehr
zum lockern das waiblinger übrig und
deshalb glaube ich dass wir jetzt meine
these darauf können sie dann etwas sagen
ohne fachmann zu sein würde ich sagen
wir haben das problem wo vor uns
hergeschoben weil wir werden uns am
schluss eben doch noch entscheiden
müssen entweder werden wir mehr opfer in
kauf nehmen müssen oder aber wir werden
um diese opfer zu vermeiden solange den
laden hier dicht schrauben müssen dass
die schäden noch sehr interessanten
vergleich in der gleichung haben sie
absichtsvoll oder nicht eine ganze menge
variablen weggelassen weil man sie auch
nicht kennt ich glaube es ist wichtig zu
sagen wir lockern ein stückchen und
gucken was passiert und wenn es uns
völlig eskaliert die zahlen der
infektion der toten der intensivbetten
der belegten völlig eskalieren dann
müssen wir noch mal wieder dagegenhalten
aber ich glaube nicht dass inzwischen
voll gelockert oder gar nicht gelockert
entscheiden müssen dazwischen ist ein
mittelweg und übrigens diesen ganzen
diskussionen und auch an den
widersprüchlichkeiten bleibt also in die
kirche dürfen sie nicht am hafen päda
demonstrationen dürfen sie also
ausländer dürfen sie hassen gott lieben
dürfen sie denn zeit nicht so richtig
das ist schon ein bisschen schwer da
sind natürlich wieder sprechen sie
dürfen in den baumarkt sie dürfen aber
nicht in einem möbelhaus das größer ist
als 800 quadratmeter und das zeigt ja
dass man da versucht einen mittelweg zu
gehen und am besten jahre alten franz
deshalb ein stückchen aus und so
entstehen diese widersprüche aber es
wird klar wie alles tasten das ist das
richtige
wir haben doch wir stehen doch im moment
in deutschland zwischen dem
französischen weg da dürfen sie am tag
eine stunde raus und an und nur abends
sorgen jetzt ausreden das ist nach sonst
wirklich ehrlich helfer sind im passiert
sie haben sie sind der mann war zu lang
isolation
sie haben wahrscheinlich niemanden zum
reden das ist können jetzt nicht einfach
jetzt auch mal zuhören lernen ja also
der französische weg praktisch da ist
echt ernsthaft streng lockdown und der
schwedische weg mit relativ wenig
öffentlich vorgegebenen regeln aber sehr
sehr viel freiwillige selbstbeschränkung
denn in wahrheit machen die schweden ist
auch nicht sehr viel anders als wir aber
ohne regeln ohne polizei macht natürlich
dann schon einen großen unterschied
finde ich und übrigens die schulen am
offen riesen unterschied entschieden hat
die schule noch offen wir sind irgendwo
dazwischen könnte auch sagen der schwede
ist der gute deutsche der
macht was dass der schwede an der
bessere deutsche das musste er macht was
was der staat gerne möchte und der stadt
musste sie noch nicht mal sagen ja das
ist vielleicht aber vielleicht hat das
auch das miteinander zu tun haben sie
darüber nachgedacht dass leute denen man
keine vorschriften macht sozusagen aus
eigener vernunft leichter dann auch so
handeln dass ich finde das schwedische
beispiel ich würde ich finde diese
ganzen ranglisten sind natürlich
interessant zum vergleichen wer hat
welche sachen gemacht aber so als
medaillenspiegel finde ich das zynisch
tut mir leid ich habe nicht überhaupt
nicht geschätzt dass sebastian kurz und
sagte wir sind besser durch das durch
die krise gekommen als andere weil wir
härter war weil wir kinder waren oder
warum auch immer
nach dem aus ist gekommen quasi in halb
europa angesteckt hat gut das können
andere also diese dieses ranking wir
haben es besser gemacht als die anderen
finde ich blöd und zynisch in so einer
situation wieder keine frage aber das
schwedische beispiel überzeugt mich
überhaupt nicht ehrlich gesagt es ist
ein völlig anderes land also als als
leitungs anleitung handlungsanleitung
für deutschland überzeugen dass man
nicht es ist ein völlig anderes land
andere mentalität anders auch etwas
anders dicht besiedelt als deutschland
zu jung und sie haben natürlich eine
deutlich höhere zahl von toten gemessen
auf die zahl der bevölkerung so können
sie können sie nehmen hab doch nicht sie
haben es interessant das ist übrigens
eine ganz wichtige beobachtung in dieser
krise sehr hohe aggressions bei den
leuten ganz ganz niedrige
konzentrationsfähigkeit zu hören was hat
der andere mag ist für uns in der von
hungern landes interessant ich habe doch
gar nicht gesagt dass sie oder wir uns
schweden zum vorbild nehmen ist ich habe
doch gesagt die deutschen befinden sich
im moment die faktor zwischen dem
schwedischen und dem französischen weg
und versuchen da irgendwie so sich so
durch zu lavieren und was sie eben
angedeutet haben wir wir lockern jetzt
ein bisschen gucken wir auf die
krankenhaus belastung doch wieder so
steigt und dann drehen wir die schraube
wieder zu das glauben sie doch selber
nicht dass das funktioniert das wenn die
leute nicht mitmachen wenn sie das jetzt
einmal den deckel vom topf nehmen dann
kriegen sie doch die wörter nicht wird
halten sie halten die leute für dümmer
als sie sind
ich glaube nicht dass die gemessen an
dem was sie sonst so öffentlich geäußert
haben wahrscheinlich diese hälfte des
topfes honig schon aus gegessen haben
das ist mir jetzt auch klar warum denn
nur noch halb voll ist weil sie sich
natürlich wesentlich schärfer
argumentiert haben ist das können sie
doch hier auch machen sie haben
wesentlich schärfer gesagt das ist
falsch es gibt keine datenbasis es gibt
keine zahlen war es alle zahlen sind
widersprüchlich hier wird ein land
stillgelegt namens deutschland der
bei den schweden die das richtig machen
bleibe aber sie waren kann es ja auch
vergleich also in maßen zumindest wenn
wir die parameter richtig in eine
vergleichbarkeit bringt mir ist dieses
wettlauf mäßigen nur nicht rächt
also dass man was von anderen anderen
land was lernen kann haben die
österreicher besser gemacht haben ist
nicht so gut gemacht was ist in
frankreich richtig oder falsch im
vergleich zu uns das finde ich ist ja
vollkommen normal dazu ist es ja auch so
schön vielfältig bis runter in die
bundesländer die jetzt unterschiedlich
agieren alles finde ich vollkommen der
grau und natürlich würden sie wenn die
zahlen radikal aufspringen wieder eine
mehrheit haben zu sagen okay wir müssen
nochmal zwei schritte zurück das hat
jetzt ist noch nicht soweit
entschuldigung entscheiden und das ist
übrigens deshalb ist diese krise auf
einer art eben auf merker so gut
zugeschnitten weil kein terrorist ihr
verfahren
sie würden jetzt sagen sie hat sich zu
oft geirrt und zu wenn also nein nein
nein nein ich finde dass ich überhaupt
nicht ich finde dass diese krise
überhaupt keine gelegenheit für polemik
ist das kann man sich ja alles glatt mal
ein bisschen kantonalen stecken lassen
ehrlich gesagt dafür ist die situation
noch zu ernst ich finde es nur so
schwierig dass sie den leuten im prinzip
den leuten etwas zumutet was ich fast
nicht zumutung sphe ich finde nämlich
wir machen zwei wochen dann gucken wir
machen zwei wochen dann gucken wir jetzt
hast du hast im grunde keine richtige
strategie dass kein richtiges ziel
es gibt keinen klaren fahrplan und ich
glaube das ist echt schwierig zu sagen
doch dann und dann können wir darauf
dass zurück weil die komme ich auf das
zurück was sie eben kurz angeschaut
haben und das dann auf grundlage von
fakten die ja ehrlich gesagt total
abitur sind weil es immer noch keiner so
richtig ganz genau mit welcher art von
krankheit ist es wohl bleiben das ist
auch genau das ist doch ehrlich und ich
glaube die leute erkenntnis als ehrlich
jetzt will ich hier nicht ganz das hohe
lied der bundesregierung sich ein singen
dann kommen wir mal zu was wir alle
schon für schwachsinn gemacht haben aber
die ehrlichkeit zu sagen wir gucken uns
das jetzt an zwei wochen und dann sehen
wir weiter
das glaube ich ist das gefühl was die
leute auch wahrnehmen die analyse diese
selber vornehmen auch wenn es ihnen
nicht gefällt wer möchte das schon nicht
jetzt gerne seinen sommerurlaub planen
dazu bräuchte es aber am horizont von
drei monaten ja den gibt es im moment
nicht sie kriegen nein aber ist wenn sie
so dass schon reichen wenn ich wüsste ob
meine kinder nicht zur schule gehen oder
nicht sommerurlaub meinetwegen aber ich
rede ja wirklich von norton die
wirklichen convenience themen ja ich
meine convenience ist auch eine wichtige
sache und das ist hier ein bisschen
essen geld ist auch wichtig rät von aber
wirklich verloren nein auch nur um das
minimum normalen einsatz ein bisschen zu
erhöhen
ich rede von kindergartenkindern die
nicht verstehen warum ihre freundin
nicht mehr mit ihnen spielen wollen weil
sie nämlich nicht begreifen dass alle zu
hause bleiben müssen
ich rede von alten leuten zu hause sind
und depressiv werden die rede von von
von menschen deren ängste wieder kehren
die sie vielleicht schon überwunden
hatten von depressiven leuten der
leitfäden im land steigt erheblichen und
steht jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen plan
der titel ein einsteiger aber es ist
immer eine arbitrage zwischen diesem
leid pegel und erlebnissen oder bildern
oder ereignissen eskalation wie in new
york wie in norditalien wie in spa muss
man ja nicht als teufel an die wand
malen aber das scheint ja auch möglich
zu sein mit ihm mit diesem virus das
kann es auch anrichten und das ist hier
noch nicht passiert insofern wenig den
mittelweg nicht was mir mehr sorgen
macht ist so eine art kontrollverlust
entschuldigung der mich echt ein stück
an
die flüchtlingskrise erinnert hier wird
jetzt geld heraus getan hier werden soll
man sagen
bürokratische oder verwaltungsrechtliche
hürden flachgelegt kontrollmechanismen
außer kraft gesetzt und einfach das geld
raus haben wir noch den finger hebt
sagte kriegt auch noch sie sind ja auch
künstler eigentlich habe ich finde sie
haben auch einen künstler krawatte und
zu und im grunde sogar versieht dieses
es ist es ist ein kontrollverlust des
staats und hinterher muss irgendeiner
dieser schaden auf wenn sie heute zur
bundesregierung gehen würden und fragen
wurden wisst ihr eigentlich viel geld ja
schon raus getan habt und wisst ihr
eigentlich wie viele leute beantragt
haben und habt ihr eigentlich und was
geprüft dann will die antwort ist gerade
keine zeit lange und das erinnert nicht
schön das erinnert mich mit allen voran
2016 als es hieß aber das ist jetzt echt
schwierig herauszufinden ob das ein
syrischer flüchtlinge ist auch recht
jeder der sagt der in syrer ist der ist
dann halt ein syrer unternehmen wir
erstmal ab wie lange geht das dann noch
gut ist es vielleicht im moment so dass
die leute auf das stillhalten weil sie
mit geld zugedeckt werden
wie viel geld ist da noch dass man diese
strategie weiter haben gehören noch
einmal sie unterschätzen die leute die
wissen dass es geld endlich ist himmel
die wissen dass das geld endlich ist es
wird hier einmal groß die schulden kann
ohne an
meinetwegen kann das richtig sein
deshalb kann sie alles muss in der krise
investieren und mach schon vollkommen
der kauf aber keiner weiß wann dafür
keiner buch im moment und das macht
mittlerweile echt ein stück angst weil
die schulden von heute sind die steuern
von morgen
es müssen eben doch
[Musik]